[Music]
[Applause]
uh scott van pelt popular uh anchor for
espn the mothership sportscaster of the
year
van peasy joining us on the program how
are you scott
i'm really good i i watching you say
bruschute
or an early early highlight of my day
that was uh i was telling you oh do you
want them up there do you want to be in
the contest here of bad song by a great
artist or great band
sure i'll i i'll uh i'll throw one out
there
and this has been heavily influenced by
my uh running mate stanford steve
because he hated this song and it made
me hate this song it's blue christmas by
elvis okay and the the more i heard it
throughout the holiday and i would hear
the uh-huh
and i thought oh it's not it's not good
is it it's unpleasant and then there's
the people in the background kind of
wailing like dogs
um
blue christmas by elvis is a is not a
song i enjoy
do you turn it off
or do you
change channel
i think i und i think i just endure it
because i feel like it's not that long
and you know christmas you get a small
window with the holiday music which i do
enjoy um but i don't like blue christmas
by elvis yeah i don't like when we have
known artists do christmas songs
no like paul mccartney simply having a
wonderful christmas time well that's a
horrendous song too
it's just i think there's some bad
christmas songs
like mariah carey i mean she's she's got
a whole a whole slew of fine christmas
music well she's the queen of christmas
there you go yeah there you go
so that's that's my entry okay that was
it that was all i wanted to talk to you
about as uh thanks dan everybody thanks
good family skills everything's great
everything's good uh two years ago today
what was the schedule like when you were
gonna do sportscenter at the end of the
evening
oklahoma city is playing utah and you
probably thought that's somewhere in the
rundown maybe
but
what what was your thought process the
day sports started to die two years ago
tonight
what i remember vividly dan about that
week was this horrible
feeling of
uh this this creep this this tide that
was slowly
rising and it was closing in and it was
it felt like a matter of time
and
i remember
specifically
thinking about the big ten tournament
because that year my beloved maryland
team was good they want to share the big
east and maryland wasn't going to play
until friday today because they were one
of the top four seeds and i just
remember thinking i just hope they get
to the game
but then i remember like
thinking get to the game meaning what
not not that the everything would stop
of course
and
that night and and dan you'd you'd be
able to relate to this so well having
done it for for years you're you're
watching games you're keeping tabs on
what's happening i was going to be doing
cut-ins which is the thing you see
during halftimes of the nba games
and
we've got you know six or seven monitors
maybe more in um
in the one room we were in because we
were running an illegal sports book out
of this area
uh i'm kidding uh but we're watching and
you could see something was going on in
oklahoma city but we didn't have the
sound up
and so then we potted the sound up to
what's what is this well the officials
just came running out
and you know twitter being what it is
you're getting you know indications
something's wrong
then it's like maybe someone's sick and
then i run up and it's woage telling us
that
something
is go bare and the season's done and
you're like oh my god i mean it went
from zero to a hundred like that and
then the reality of it lands like a like
an absolute anvil on your head for what
it meant
because in looking back i mean i don't
believe this is hyperbole to say it
the nba and go bears positive completely
changed the direction of covet in the
united states of america yeah
because when the nba said we're done and
the nhl followed suit and then you know
awfully uh the the the ncaa tournament
said we're done because that that's was
nothing that could be revisited
unfortunately you know obviously stanley
cup and the nba were able to continue
but
i just
it was incredible from around 8 o'clock
eastern that night
to going on live because the kings
pelicans game which they were going to
play
and then i think it the reality for them
landed like what the hell are we doing
like we're not doing this course there
was an official that had had been in the
utah game not a couple of days earlier
and the pelicans are like why like
because remember mentally where we were
then it was this this horrifying thought
that if you got it what did it mean
maybe we were you were doomed so
i don't know there was just so many
things swirling
and with the benefit of a couple of
years it's interesting sort of how some
things are maybe more clear and
um it was a lot man
but how do you think history is going to
treat rudy gobert
well i mean they'll always remember him
doing what he did with the microphones
and and making light of it um
but i i remember this dan i remember
that night saying to roy chung on the
air and i said i tried to be as clear as
i could i said i'm thinking out loud i'm
not trying to play doctor here because
we didn't know but i said
is it maybe a good indication
that rudy felt well enough that he
wanted to play
but they told him he couldn't you know
because you know what i'm saying like at
that point in 2020 if you're positive
for kovid like oh god maybe i'm maybe
i'm going to die by tomorrow well as it
turned out and this particularly in the
athletic world gratefully that that
really
nobody really got that horribly ill
they're i mean uh in professional
athletics um
and i think they'll remember that he
acted like an idiot and he was too
casual with the doing making fun of
things
um
but they'll remember hit they'll always
remember his name because he was the
first big time athlete and i think
they'll remember that he was the one
that made the nba slam the brakes which
led everybody in our country to take
take it much more seriously than they
had been prior to that wednesday night
paulie and i were talking about this
recently that we went two months without
any live sports
and
this is three hours that i'm doing a
show
yeah
you're doing a highlight show so you
kind of build in highlights in a
highlight show at what point did a light
go on and say
this is the let's pivot and we can still
do this every single night
i don't want to be over
you know not i just don't want to be
dramatic about it because there were
people doing far more
important work we all understand this i
just say that for someone whose job it
is to to do an hour-long show about the
night sports
and the highlights
and there are none it was mentally just
you got to a point where it was just
like what are we going to do and let's
remember the direction of the
conversation at the time dan we had the
george floyd murder in minnesota in
minnesota we had the bubble wallace
incident in in talladega which you know
people what was that it was that it was
simply just an innocuous thing that
happened to me in his stall whatever the
case might have been but remember the
tenor of the conversation in our country
and a lot of that occupied our time and
there's a
segment of our population that always
wants you to stick to sports and i
remember thinking i'd happily stick to
sports i just i'd love for you to tell
me what they are because i'm i'm i'm
fresh out of sports over here and
we were we creatively came up with some
stuff i remember
um
thinking and it's interesting our
president jimmy pataro had some a very
similar idea and we all kind of lumped
it together just how do we honor people
whose seasons ended because there were
so many athletes across the country that
were on the cusp think of where we are
right now you're ready to crown a
champion in some sport maybe it's hockey
maybe it's
basketball or whatever and we we came up
with the concept of senior night and
that became
um
it benefited them maybe but it certainly
benefited us we needed content and and
it was really cool to find out that that
meant things to people around the
country we were really really you know
proud that we were able to honor them
appropriately and then we had
dan we had you know last dance and we
turned the last dance into content and
salute to our group salute to my guy
jmac jace mccallum was a
one of our producers on the show he went
back to him through the bulls season and
found bad beats from the bulls from the
bowls 1996 season and we're showing bad
beats and it was i remember people
thinking oh my god like because you
imagine being some poor guy that was on
the wrong end of a beat you know however
many years ago and now now you're
reliving it again thinking yeah i had
the jazz that night or whatever but
um i
it we we i think we talked to jeff
paston like 42 times we talked to adrian
warjanowski probably the same because it
was some version every day dan you
remember it of the same thing hey what
do we think they're going to do what's
the bubble going to look like when might
they compete what are the protocols
going to be it was
um
it was just
you you did it three times more than i
did uh three hours more a day i did i
just wonder this did you mentally did
you just feel like i don't know that i
can continue to do this like did you
feel like your brain was in a nod at
times
it was strange coming in you don't have
any choice you have to do it but i
remember
it takes me about 12 minutes to get to
work and it felt like those 12 minutes i
would dread because i was like i
i don't know how to do this now and look
we we have it great and i'm not i don't
mean to diminish anything this is just
our vacuum my world trying to entertain
this audience and i'd come into paulie
and i'd go
what do you got
and i i never relied on i don't think we
relied on each other so much over that
two-month span because i said we still
have to do it we may not we may be you
know whining and moaning and but we got
to do it we're a diversion for people
around the country we i don't care what
it is we got to do it and
you know we just
our ratings went up
our audience grew with no sports
because i i think our approach was a
smart approach
but you know we were all in it together
and i said to the audience i don't have
answers
no but we're trying and we'll be here
every single day for you but i just
remember i don't know if i've ever had a
challenge like that where you did have
tom brady that was a great story story
like we had moments pockets where you're
going oh let's grab on to that and you
would hold on to that life raft a little
bit longer because you didn't have
anything else to talk about
and and you made something that maybe
was not as big a little bit bigger
as a result but
it was
i'll look back on that as one of the
proudest moments i've ever had with this
show
and you probably i'm gonna guess look
back on what you guys did two years ago
the start of two years ago with your
team
without a doubt dan i i think what it
speaks to and you certainly have this is
there is a relationship with the
audience and when the when the audience
knows you and they know you
sort of
they know your voice they know what you
stand for they know who you are that you
they know you're not going to try to bs
them and and when
you're just trying to get through all of
it together and you recognize that what
you are and and we got wonderful notes
from people that that you represent this
thing you're some light that's on and
it's comfortable and i'm thinking i'm
glad it's comfortable for you because
i'm i'm over here like i'm a one-man
band playing at kazoo and banging on the
drums like a chimpanzee i'm just trying
to make noise for the hour and but yes i
mean
certainly the the the senior night stuff
uh it was it was
it felt great to be able to give
somebody something just i see you i
acknowledge your team and we know you
were almost did something awesome and it
got taken
no one's fault right but
what's what's incredible
right now two years later
last week i was down in durham for
carolina duke and and i you know you're
in the building for that last game
and more than anything
i was just struck by what 9 400 people
sound like what it feels like the energy
the shared experience and then this
sport what sport provides like duke was
there for a party and carolina was not
there for a party man they were there to
win and they did and all of what just
coming home from that i was just moved
by the shared experience the sound of it
the feeling of it and then the theater
of what sports and only sports are and i
i know you and i both we've talked about
this just how fortunate we feel to to do
what we do and to catalog this and to
get to know the people that do it and
then just then just to watch the games
and god without the fans there which
credits all the sports that came back
because
watching sports help
but fans make sports what they are they
really do and
years from now when we look back on that
year the nfl played games with nobody
it's just so odd it's so jarring and
then it became jarring when we saw
people there again you had to reacquaint
yourself with what all that felt like so
it's um
i don't know man it's wild in some ways
it feels like it was a hundred years ago
and
in the midst of it it felt like it would
never end you know it was just this
quicksand that you just were trying to
keep your head
and keep your mind afloat and um i don't
know well it wasn't an honor i don't
know it's just what we are lucky enough
to do but i'm
i was proud of what we tried to do then
just like the same thing that you're you
know you're gonna fill three great hours
today and every day that's what you do
and that's what we try to do
great to catch up with you as always
scott congratulations on the honor of
sportscaster of the year i appreciate
that i i you know i got a nice phone
call i i tied ernie johnson didn't beat
him but i tied him so i'll you know i'm
happy i don't know if we have to cut a
trophy in half i don't care i got
something but it's like a tie goes to
the runner so it's okay i mean you were
safe at first and you you get to have a
trophy you get to kick ernie johnson's
ass in a 40. i really feel like i would
really
no i don't i'd probably pop a hamstring
in an achilles
thank you scott
be well damn that's scott van pelt espn
sports center anchor